This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。100%纯人工。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及建立适应力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”和百分号，可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听《回首当年》播客。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同仁喜剧演员以及我们最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊20世纪80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《回首当年》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲。这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去这样做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听并了解《艰难学步》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控产下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。
Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, let's talk about destiny or something that feels strangely attached to it. Let's talk about personality, whether it's fixed or it can be changed, how it shapes our future, our beliefs, maybe even how happy we are. Personality is like a little bit of a black box. Like we know it's shaped by nature and nurture. We know that genetics are involved. How we were raised is kind of involved. But I think as we get older, we become more aware of the parts of ourselves that
欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身处世界何地。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析我们20多岁时的心理学。今天，我们来聊聊命运，或者某种感觉与之有着奇怪联系的东西。让我们聊聊性格，探讨它是固定不变的还是可以改变的，它是如何塑造我们的未来、我们的信念，甚至也许还有我们的幸福感。性格就像一个黑匣子。就像我们知道它是由先天和后天塑造的。我们知道基因参与其中。我们的成长经历也多多少少参与其中。但我认为随着我们年龄的增长，我们越来越意识到自己身上的那些部分，它们……
are holding us back and that, you know, we really would wish for something different. Well, today I have the honor of interviewing someone who has investigated that very possibility. What if we could be ourselves but better by rewiring our personality. I want to welcome on author and journalist Oga Hazan. Thank you for joining us. Absolutely. Thanks for having me. I'm very, very excited for this episode and this topic in general. But before we kind of jump into it, but can you briefly introduce yourself to the audience and your work? Sure. My name's Olga Hazan, and I'm a staff writer at The Atlantic Magazine,
正拖累着我们，而且，你知道的，我们真的很希望有所不同。嗯，今天我很荣幸能采访一位深入研究过这种可能性的人。如果我们能保持自我，但通过重塑性格变得更好，会怎样呢？我想欢迎作家兼记者奥尔加·哈赞。谢谢你加入我们。当然。谢谢邀请我。我非常非常期待这一期节目以及这个总体的议题。但在我们深入探讨之前，你能向听众简要介绍一下你自己和你的工作吗？当然。我叫奥尔加·哈赞，我是《大西洋月刊》的特约撰稿人，
and I'm also an author of books. This is my second book, and it is actually kind of stems from a cover story I did for The Atlantic a few years ago. So that's my backstory. And you're not going to give us any spoilers. I feel like the cover story, like you go into it kind of in the book, right? Yeah, yeah, I can, yeah, I can, I can, I can give you a spoiler. So the cover story, I kind of experimented very lightly with changing my personality, but then I kind of realized that I needed
我也是一名图书作家。这是我的第二本书，它其实有点源于几年前我为《大西洋月刊》撰写的一篇封面报道。这就是我的背景故事。你不会给我们任何剧透吧。我觉得这篇封面报道，你在书中也会详细讲到，对吧？是的，是的，我可以，是的，我可以，我可以，我可以剧透一下。所以封面报道中，我非常轻微地尝试了改变我的性格，但后来我意识到我需要……
to do more and that it, you know, kind of letting up on the experiment, I backtracked. I noticed that I was sort of falling back into old patterns. So the book is really an overview of the five traits of personality, my personal attempts to change on three of them. And because the other two, I actually don't need to change. They're fine. They're very high in me as it is. But I do interview other people who increased on those traits through various methods. We're going to get to that because I feel like it's such an interesting premise.
做更多的事情，而且，你知道的，在放松了实验之后，我又退缩了。我注意到我似乎又回到了老习惯中。所以这本书其实是对性格五大特质的概述，以及我在其中三个特质上做出的个人尝试。至于另外两个特质，其实我不需要改变。它们很好。它们在我身上本来就很强。但我采访了其他人，他们通过各种方法在这些特质上得到了提升。我们接下来会谈到这一点，因为我觉得这是一个非常有趣的前提。
But I do also want to talk about how you became a journalist, how you became a writer. I think as much as I love interviewing people about the very, you know, amazing niche things that they're doing and they're like, whether it's psychology or neuroscience or anything like that, you know, this podcast is for people in their 20s and a lot of people probably aspire to do what you do. Can you kind of talk us through how you got from maybe graduating high school to where you are now? Sure. Yeah. Wow, that's a long time ago. Yeah. Just because I... of you your entire life.
但我还想聊聊你是如何成为一名记者、如何成为一名作家的。我想，尽管我很喜欢采访人们关于他们正在做的那些非常了不起的小众事情，无论是心理学、神经科学还是类似的事情，你知道的，这个播客是为20多岁的人准备的，很多人可能渴望做你所做的事情。你能给我们讲讲你是如何从高中毕业走到今天的吗？当然。哇，那是很久以前的事了。是的。只是因为我……你的一生。
Please and thank you. Graduated from high school like 20 years ago. Then I went to college, did not major in journalism, but really found myself drawn to journalism. I did an internship in journalism. And then I went to graduate school after I graduated from college, which is not like a necessary step for anyone listening at home, but it is something that I did. then I got a job at the Washington Post out of graduate school and I worked there for a brief time. And then I moved to the Atlantic in 2013.
请和谢谢。大约20年前高中毕业。然后我上了大学，主修的不是新闻学，但发现自己真的被新闻学所吸引。我做了一份新闻实习。大学毕业后我读了研究生，对于在家的听众来说，这并不是必经的一步，但这是我做过的事情。然后研究生毕业后我在《华盛顿邮报》找到了一份工作，我在那里工作了一小段时间。然后我在2013年转到了《大西洋月刊》。
And I've worked at the Atlantic ever since. And I've done a couple different jobs there, but I've mostly been a writer covering like health and human behavior. Well, that's the perfect topic for this. Do you remember like what your first big piece of writing was, like your first article where you were like, oh my gosh like I'm a journalist yeah um that probably was so when I did my internship in college I wrote one story um during that internship it was complex why I only wrote one but it that that was like the amount that I was allowed to write um and it was about online gaming addiction um and uh I remember when it came out I felt so just accomplished like I was like a year
从那以后我就一直在《大西洋月刊》工作。我在那里做过几个不同的工作，但主要是一名撰稿人，报道健康和人类行为。嗯，这真是这个话题的绝佳切入点。你还记得你第一篇大型作品是什么吗，比如你的第一篇文章，当时你觉得，哦天哪，我是一名记者。是的，嗯，那可能是在大学实习的时候，我写了一篇报道……在实习期间，我只写了一篇文章，为什么只写一篇很复杂，但那就是允许我写的篇幅……它是关于网络游戏成瘾的……我记得文章发表的时候，我感到非常有成就感……就像我是……
Yes, like my life is all coming together. And of course, like, I wouldn't be a full-time writer for, I think, eight years after that. But it was, it was like very good motivation to keep going. You know, I love stories like that where it's like, okay, just because your dream isn't happening right now doesn't mean that it's not going to come true eventually. Like, as you said, you had this like, what sounds like this big accomplished moment and, you know, it really didn't come full circle until, what did you say, like 10 years ago, almost maybe 12? years ago, which we love hearing those stories on the show. Let's talk about this book. The premise of this book was basically that cover story and this idea that you wanted to change your personality.
是的，感觉我的生活全盘走上正轨了。当然，在那之后的八年里，我大概都不会成为全职作家。但这真的是一个非常好的动力，让我坚持下去。你知道，我喜欢这样的故事，就是说，仅仅因为你的梦想现在没有实现，并不意味着它最终不会成真。正如你所说，你有这样一个听起来很有成就感的时刻，你知道，直到——你刚才怎么说的？——大约10年前，差不多快12年前，才真正水到渠成，我们很喜欢在节目中听到这样的故事。我们来聊聊这本书。这本书的前提基本上就是那篇封面报道，以及你想要改变性格的想法。
Why did you feel like it was necessary? Like, why did you feel like you had to do that? Yeah. So your personality, you know, a lot of people think it's sort of like what you like or dislike or sort of the kinds of things you say or whatever. But it's really a lot about your reactions to situations and kind of like something comes across your way and are you like, yes, let's do it. Are you like, oh, I don't know about that? Or, you know, it's kind of like how you interact with the world. And I noticed that a lot of how I was interacting with the world was not helping me, really.
为什么你觉得这是必要的？为什么你觉得自己必须这么做？是的。所以你的性格，你知道，很多人认为这有点像你的好恶，或者你说的那些话之类。但它其实很大程度上关乎你对特定情况的反应，有点像有什么事情发生了，你会说“太好了，我们干吧”？还是会说“哦，我不太确定”？或者，你知道，这有点像你与世界互动的方式。我注意到，我与世界互动的很多方式其实并没有真正帮到我。
So the intro to the book kind of gives a good overview of this. But I had this day, this is before I had a kid. And it was like, now having had a kid, I'm like, wow, this was actually like a fantastic day. I should have just appreciated it. But, you know, it was like I got stuck in traffic. I got a bad haircut. I got photos taken that looked really bad. I had a stressful thing where I had to like pick my mom up at the airport, but I had to go grocery shopping before.
所以书的引言部分对此作了很好的概述。但我有这样一天，那是在我有孩子之前。当时的感觉是，现在有了孩子后，我觉得，哇，这其实是个美妙的一天。我本该好好珍惜它的。但是，你知道，就像我堵车了。我剪了个糟糕的发型。拍出来的照片看起来非常糟糕。我有一件压力很大的事，得去机场接我妈妈，但在这之前我还得去买杂货。
But there was like a delay at the grocery store. And then I was going to be late to pick up my mom. And it was like this whole thing. And I just had a meltdown. I got back to my Airbnb. that I was staying in and I drank wine and like cried to my boyfriend at the time and was just like, I hate everything. And then I kind of got to thinking and I was like, even like me saying that now to you, I'm like, wow, that is so whiny and like unappreciative of the fact that like
结果杂货店排队耽误了。然后我去接我妈妈就要迟到了。整个过程就是这样。然后我就崩溃了。我回到了我住的Airbnb……
that day, you know, I was able to buy groceries. I was in Miami. Like I got myself to Miami. me. I, you know, was getting a haircut, like spa day for me. You know, I got professional photos taken. Like, you know, and it was sort of like I had this realization that like, wow, I can take anything good and positive and maybe, or maybe even just like mediocre, right? Like a lot of things that happen in life are kind of like, oh, that was whatever. You know, and I have a tendency to dwell on the negatives and to like emphasize the negatives and create these stories out of the negatives that were not serving me. And it was making me like not enjoy my life like to the extent that I, that it could have
我当时住在那儿，喝了酒，向当时的男朋友哭诉，就觉得，我讨厌这一切。然后我开始思考，甚至像我现在这样对你说这些，我都觉得，哇，这真是太爱抱怨了，而且完全不感恩，因为……那天，你知道的，我买得起杂货。我在迈阿密。就像我把自己带到了迈阿密。我，你知道的，在剪头发，就像为我准备的水疗日。你知道的，我拍了专业照片。就像，你知道的，我突然意识到，哇，我可以把任何美好、积极的事情，甚至可能，或者也许只是平庸的事情，对吧？生活中的很多事情其实都是“哦，也就那样吧”。你知道的，我有纠结于负面情绪的倾向，喜欢放大负面情绪，并从负面情绪中编造出那些对毫无益处的叙事。这让我无法尽情享受我的生活……
and should have been enjoyed. And so that's kind of the long and the short of it, why I decided to change. That's actually really interesting. And can I be honest? Maybe I'm like, maybe I need to change my personality because I had a day like that like literally yesterday. I like, I'm sorry. I know I literally even got my hair cut and like I didn't like my hair cut and like my mom was literally in town yesterday as well. And that's like honestly crazy. Um, so like you're, I'm like hearing that story and like no, like you, you just feel
本来可以也应该享受到的程度。所以这就是我决定改变的长话短短。这其实真的很有趣。我能说实话吗？也许我是，也许我需要改变我的性格，因为我literally昨天就过了这样的一天。我literally甚至剪了头发，我不喜欢我的剪发，而且我妈妈昨天也literally在城里。这简直太疯狂了。所以，就像你说的，我听到这个故事时，心想，不，你只是在感受……
your emotions, girl. There's a time and a place to feel your emotions. But you can feel your emotions and also like look at the bright side. Yeah, no. It's just really funny. And I think like what you're really pointing at is like this wasn't like a one off. situation. Like you had seen this pattern of not being able to enjoy your life. And what I'm hearing is that you were like, okay, well, something needs to change in me. Why did you hone in on personality and like specific building blocks of personality rather than something else? Why didn't you like speak spiritual enlightenment? Why didn't you like say to yourself, oh, I need to change something about my lifestyle? Like did you feel, yeah, what was like the focus on changing?
你的情绪，女孩。感受情绪是有时间和地点的。但你可以在感受情绪的同时，也看到光明的一面。是的，没错。这真的很搞笑。我想你真正指出的是，这并不是一次性的。情况。你已经看到了这种无法享受生活的模式。我听到的是，你当时想，好吧，我身上有些东西需要改变。为什么你偏偏聚焦于性格和性格的具体构建模块，而不是其他东西？你为什么不寻求精神启蒙？你为什么不对自己说，哦，我需要改变生活方式？你当时觉得，是的，对改变的关注点是什么……
what I'm guessing is like neuroticism, right, like as a building block. Yeah. So neuroticism was one of the things I wanted to change. So neuroticism is one of the five traits and it's just anxiety and depression, right? And I had a lot of that. I had a lot of anxiety and a lot of kind of negativity, as I mentioned. But there are other elements of personality and they sort of encompass those other things that you mentioned.
我猜是神经质，对吧，作为一个构建模块。是的。所以神经质是我想要改变的事情之一。神经质是五大特质之一，它就是焦虑和抑郁，对吧？我有很多这种情绪。我有很多焦虑和很多负面情绪，正如我所提到的。但性格中还有其他要素，它们涵盖了你提到的那些其他东西。
So actually, as far as like improving my neuroticism, a big thing I actually looked to was Buddhism and a lot of Buddhist teachings because a lot of neuroticism, it's not about like reducing the number of things that happen to you that are bad. It's, I mean, although like if you're like addicted to drugs and like that's why bad things keep happening to you, like that's something to look to. But let's say you're like a functional person who's, you know, living like a basically normal life, it's going to be a lot easier to change your reactions to the things that happen to you than it is to like make every single thing in the world go your way.
所以事实上，就改善我的神经质而言，我实际求助的一个重要方面是佛教和许多佛教教义，因为很多神经质，它不是关于减少发生在你身上的坏事的数量。它是——我的意思是，尽管如果你对毒品上瘾，这就是坏事不断发生在你身上的原因，那确实是需要关注的问题。但假设你是一个正常运转的人，过着（基本上）正常的生活，那么改变你对发生的事情的反应，要比让世界上每一件事都如你所愿容易得多。
So that's why I kind of like looked inward. And personality does encompass a lot of those things that you mentioned. So like spirituality, Buddhism has a lot to say about depression and anxiety. And you know, as far as like lifestyle, that was really more extroversion. Like I wanted to become more extroverted. And that was a big part. Lifestyle was a big part of that is sort of how often do you go out to socialize? And do you make an effort to do that?
这就是为什么我有点向内看。性格确实包含了你提到的很多东西。所以比如灵性，佛教对抑郁和焦虑有很多看法。你知道，就生活方式而言，那其实更多是外向性。我想要变得更外向。这是很大一部分。生活方式是其中的很大一部分，也就是你多久出去社交一次？你为此做出努力了吗？
You know, not just like do you sit by the phone and wait for people to contact you? But do you make connections? Do you try to get out there? So those are things that I did. But I called it personality change because personality includes all that. Okay. That makes a lot more sense. So in this like endeavor to change your personality, did you figure out like who the happiest
你知道，不只是坐在电话旁边等别人联系你？而是去建立联系？你试着走出去吗？所以这些是我做过的事情。但我把它称为性格改变，因为性格包含了所有这些。好的。这说得通多了。所以在这种试图改变性格的努力中，你有没有弄清楚最快乐的人……
kinds of people were? Like was there an assumption that like the happiest kinds of people are extroverted and are lower neuroticism and like high and openness to experiences? Like thinking about like the big five, what did you come across in your research? Yeah. So people are not going to be thrilled to hear this, but the happiest people are like, high in all the traits except for neuroticism. So there's five traits. I will just briefly say what they are. So openness to experience, happy people are high in that because that's like, yeah,
是哪种人？比如，是否存在一种假设，即最快乐的人是外向的，神经质程度较低，并且对新体验具有高度的开放性？结合大五人格，你在研究中发现了什么？是的。人们听到这个可能不会太高兴，但最快乐的人是所有特质得分都很高，除了神经质。所以有五个特质。我简单说一下它们是什么。所以对体验的开放性，快乐的人在这项上很高，因为那是，是的，
spiritual but not religious, like creative, imaginative, conscientiousness, which is like getting stuff done. So it's like being places on time and being like healthy and exercising, happy people tend to be high in that. Extroversion, extroverts are happier. That's like a really consistent finding in psychology. Unfortunately, I was, I'm an introvert and I was not thrilled to hear that. Agreeableness. Agreeable people are happier. They're always like making friends and going to baby showers and what have you. And then neuroticism is the one that's correlated with unhappiness. And so the opposite of it is emotional stability. That's what it's called. And people who are high in
精神上的而不是宗教上的，比如有创造力、有想象力；尽责性，也就是把事情做好。所以比如按时到达各个地方，保持健康和锻炼，快乐的人往往在这项上很高。外向性，外向的人更快乐。这是心理学中一个非常一致的发现。不幸的是，我是，我是一个内向的人，听到这个我可高兴不起来。宜人性。宜人的人更快乐。他们总是结交朋友、去参加迎婴派对等等。而神经质是与不快乐呈负相关的那一个。所以它的对立面是情绪稳定性。这就是它的名字。在这项上得分高的人……
are happier. Kind of rough. Not going to laugh. Yeah, I know. I know. I'm an introvert. And I have anxiety. I think like maybe caveat, like I'll put the caveat in.
更快乐。有点艰难。我不打算笑。是的，我知道，我知道。我是一个内向的人。我有焦虑。我想也许可以加上一个限定条件……
Like sometimes I think that it's like are introverts less happy or the scales by which we measure happiness just obviously overly influenced by extroverts, right? Because who's going to participate in those early studies that like created indicators for happiness. It's going to be the people who have a lot of friends who are going to invite them to participate and who are like, yeah, I'll do this. I'll go out. Like, I'll get paid to, like, sit in a room with a stranger for an hour. Like, so sometimes I think that. And I also do think that, like, what we'll get to is, even if you don't think you can change your personality, you can most certainly manage it. And you can manage, like, medications and you can manage lifestyle
有时候我认为，这是内向的人不够快乐，还是我们衡量快乐的标准显然受到了外向者的过度影响，对吧？因为谁会去参加那些为快乐创造指标的早期研究呢？会是那些有很多朋友的人，他们会邀请这些人参加，并且会说“行，我愿意做这个。我出去。行，我愿意拿报酬和一个陌生人在一个房间里坐一个小时”。所以有时我这么想。而且我也确实认为，正如我们接下来要讨论的，即使你认为自己无法改变性格，你也绝对可以管理它。你可以管理，比如药物，你可以管理生活方式……
factors and routine and therapists. So don't see this as like a curse. upon your name if you kind of associate with some of those other traits. But this kind of leads me to my next question. At what age do you think our personality really starts to stick? At what age do you think we really feel like stuck in who we are? Yeah. So I would say there's not an age at which we start to stick in who we are. So that used to be the thinking this like influential psychologist named William James
因素、日常习惯和治疗师。所以如果你与其中一些其他特质产生共鸣，不要把这看作是对你的诅咒。但这让我想到了我的下一个问题。你认为我们在什么年龄，性格才真正开始定型？你认为我们在什么年龄才会真正觉得自己被困在了当前的自我中？是的。所以我想说，并不存在一个我们开始定型的年龄。所以以前的想法是，一个名叫威廉·詹姆斯的有影响力的心理学家……
had this infamous sort of quote that like the character, is set like plaster by the age of 30, which is relevant for your podcast for people in their 20s. So, I mean, even he said like in your 20s, you can still change. But kind of more recent research has found that that's not really true, that people kind of continue to change throughout their lives, even naturally, even if you don't really do anything to try to change, your personality is going to kind of shift from decade to decade. You're going to be a different person. when you have kids and like a job than you were in college, then you were in high school, you know, and that is like freeing.
有一个臭名昭著的引言，说人的性格在30岁时就像石膏一样定型了，这对于你的播客、对于20多岁的人来说很相关。所以，即使他说过，在你20多岁的时候，你仍然可以改变。但更近的研究发现，这其实并不是真的，人们在一生中会不断改变，即使是自然而然地，即使你没有做任何努力去改变，你的性格也会随着十年又十年而发生某种转变。你会成为一个不同的人。当你有孩子、有工作时，与你在大学时、在高中时相比，你会是不同的人，你知道的，这很解放。
And it's kind of scary, but it's also kind of nice that like you're not going to be like if you're not crazy about something, you know, about yourself or about your life, you're not stuck with it forever. That is very, very freeing. And even like as we get into like older age as well, something that I, like a statistic that I really like to talk about is how by the time people reach like 60 and 70, symptoms of mental illness really decline, which I don't know. I've always thought about that and been like, oh, that sounds great. Like, you can't wait for that. Yeah, can't wait for that. Like, maybe I'll have 10 years of just
这有点吓人，但也很美好，因为你不会——如果你对自己的某些方面、对自己的生活不是特别狂热，你不会永远被困在其中。这非常非常令人解放。甚至当我们进入老年时，我真正喜欢谈论的一个统计数据是，当人们到了60岁和70岁时，精神疾病的症状真的会下降，我不知道。我一直都在想这个，并心想，哦，听起来太棒了。就像，等不及那一刻了。是的，等不及了。也许我会有10年……
like bliss. But it is like a really beautiful thing that you mentioned this. I hear this a lot, like another myth about personality change slash personality stuckness is by the time you reach 25, like your frontal lobe is fully developed. And I think we kind of think like, okay, so that's it. Like, this is who I'm always going to be. What evidence did you find, like, on the contrary? Before I, like, really dive into your personal experiment. Yeah. So, um, so there's two kind of, um, branches of evidence to the contrary. Um, so first, uh, your frontal lobe being fully formed doesn't really mean anything about your personality because we don't have like a lobe in our brain that is where the personality lives. So like even if they study like brain changes or,
纯粹的幸福。但你提到这一点真的非常美妙。我经常听到这种说法，关于性格改变/性格定型的另一个神话是，当你长到25岁时，你的前额叶皮层就完全发育成熟了。我想我们往往会想，好吧，就是这样。这就是我永远的为人了。与此相反，你找到了什么证据？在我真正深入讨论你的个人实验之前。是的。所以，有两类……
or, you know, like those like fMRI studies where it's like brains lighting up, those don't necessarily correlate perfectly with personality necessarily. So there's kind of two elements to this. The first is that when researchers have followed people, you know, and given them personality tests over and over across the years, they do find that people change. You know, they tend to change in certain ways over time. So like you mentioned, that people become kind of mentally healthier in old age. Neuroticism does go down naturally across your life. So if you feel like you're very anxious and depressed, usually in older age, people become less so. So that's a sort of just naturally happens. You don't have to do anything. You don't have to like take any
相反的证据分支。所以首先，你的前额叶皮层完全形成，并不意味着你的性格有什么变化，因为我们的大脑中没有一个专门存放性格的叶。所以即使他们研究大脑变化，或者……或者，你知道的，比如那些fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）研究，显示大脑亮起来的那种，那些并不一定与性格完全对应。所以这里面有两个要素。首先，当研究人员多年来一直追踪人们，并一遍又一遍地给他们做性格测试时，他们确实发现人们在改变。你知道，随着时间的推移，他们往往会以某些特定方式改变。正如你提到的，人们在老年时心理会变得更健康。神经质在一生中确实会自然下降。所以如果你觉得自己非常焦虑和抑郁，通常在老年时，人们的这种情绪会减少。所以这是一种自然发生的现象。你不需要做什么。你不需要服用……
Lexapro that naturally happens for most people. The other element of this is that if you actually try to change, it can happen even faster. So there's been studies that show that people who get therapy, for example, become less neurotic. And in a short period of time, they become a lot less neurotic than you would expect them to having just like naturally, you know, decline in neuroticism. And the same with some of the studies that I cover in my book. Researchers who have given people these like challenges, you know, people will say, I'd really like to become more extroverted. I'd like to make more friends. And they're like, okay, every day for or whatever, every week for a month, reach out to someone new and have coffee with them or have, you know,
百忧解（Lexapro），这对于大多数人来说是自然发生的。这里的另一个要素是，如果你真的试图改变，它甚至可以发生得更快。有研究表明，例如接受心理治疗的人，他们的神经质会减少。在很短的时间内，他们的神经质减少的程度，会远远超过你预期他们仅靠自然……你知道，神经质自然下降所达到的程度。我书中所涵盖的一些研究也是如此。研究人员给人们这些挑战，你知道，人们会说：“我真的很想变得更外向。我想交更多朋友。”然后研究人员会说：“好的，每个月……”或者每个星期，主动联系一个新朋友并和他们喝杯咖啡，或者共进午餐，等等。他们在一段时间内可能做了大概五到十次这样的挑战。根据他们在开始和结束时参加的性格测试，他们实际上发现自己的外向性确实有所增长。所以，你不仅会自然改变，还可以通过努力去改变。那么内向之类的特质呢？我一直认为它们是非常天生的。就像这是一种基因，哦，天哪，我不知道，比如基因倾向，这是气质，但你的意思是，其实并不是，它更多是后天因素。好吧，就像环境因素。抱歉。
lunch with them or whatever. And they do maybe like five to ten challenges like that over a period of time. They actually find that they do grow in extroversion based on personality tests that they take at the beginning and the end. So not only do you naturally change, you can also change through effort. So are things like introversion? Like I always thought that they were very innate. Like it's a genetic, oh my, I don't know, like genetic predisposition, it's temperament, but you're saying that actually know it's more of a nurture factor. Well, it's like environment. Sorry.
所以两者都有。基因大约占我们性格的40%到60%。即便如此，这也并非直接决定的。如果你想想你的父母，你可能并不完全像他们中的任何一个，对吧？你可能会觉得，你有他们的某些元素，但你不是他们的双胞胎。就像你，大多数人都是——我的意思是，通常人们听到这个会感到宽慰。
Yeah. So it's both. So genetics is responsible for about 40 to 60% of our personality. And even then, it's not like direct. Like if you think about either of your parents, you're probably not exactly like either of them, right? You're probably like, you have like elements of them, but you're not like they're twin. Like you kind of, most people are, I mean, usually people are relieved to hear this.
并不会完全像任何一个父母，对吧？所以你会得到一点，比如你得到了一些成分。所以我对焦虑有一种天然的倾向，因为我的父母都非常焦虑，对吧？但与此同时，还有其他……性格中还有另外40%到60%的成分，我们并不真正知道它具体来自哪里。它不一定是你父母抚养你的方式。它就像是那种，但它也像是你的朋友。比如，你上大学了吗？你做什么工作？你知道，你会努力阅读自助书籍吗？它有点像你所做的事情以及融入你自身的那些东西，这些构成了性格的另一部分。所以我所说的就是这种因素：是的，如果你有两个完全书生气且讨厌和人说话的父母，你自然会觉得自己非常内向。但如果你……
like not exactly like either, either parent, right? So you get a little bit, like you get some ingredients. So I have like a natural proclivity toward anxiety because both my parents are very anxious, right? But at the same time, there's other, there's like this, you know, 40 to 60 other percent of personality that we don't really know where specifically it comes from. It's not necessarily like the way your parents raised you. It's like, it's like kind of that, but it's also like your friends. It's like, did you go to college? What kind of job do you have? You know, do you make an effort to like read self-help books? It's kind of like the stuff that you do and absorb into yourself that creates that other part of personality. So that's the kind of element that I'm
从事了一份销售工作，整天和人说话，你周围的每个人都很外向，而且因为外向而获得击掌和晋升。那你就会比你天生自带的性格要更外向一点，如果这说得通的话。所以这有点像在某种程度上，强化确实起作用。就像，是的，绝对是的。看，我觉得这真的很有趣，因为我的父母完全截然相反。他们是“异性相吸”的完美定义。我父亲是个全职爸爸……
talking about is that like, yeah, if you have two parents who are totally bookish and hate talking to people, you're going to naturally be kind of like, I feel really introverted. But if, but if you, you know, go into a job in sales and you talk to people, you know, all day and everyone around you is extroverted and you get like high fives and promotions for being extroverted. Like you're going to be a little bit more extroverted than you naturally would be, if that makes sense. So it's kind of like at some point reinforcement does kind of work. Like yeah, yeah, absolutely. Yeah. See, I find this really interesting because like my parents are so totally opposite each other. like they're the perfect definition of like opposites attract like my dad is like a stay-at-home dad
我们管他叫“慈善妻子”，他经营着一家非营利组织——向澳大利亚的难民儿童回馈援助；然后我母亲是个雷厉风行的首席执行官，而且她就像奥尔加一样——她是我见过的神经质程度最低的人，我从来没见过那个女人流汗，她一点也不焦虑，没有什么事能难倒她。而我父亲则完全相反，也不是说他完全焦虑，但他非常焦虑、非常存在主义、在脑子里对很多深奥的事情想得很多。很有趣，看到我和我姐姐总是开玩笑说，就像，你知道，我们俩有一个人继承了我妈妈的基因，我和另一个姐姐继承了我爸爸的基因。
and like we call him like a charity wife like he runs like a non-for-profit like giving backs to refugee children in Australia and like then my mom is like a like badass like CEO and like she has like she is Oger like she is the lowest person like the lowest neurotic neuroticism levels I have ever seen in an individual like I have never seen that woman break a sweat she is not anxious at all like nothing phases her and then my dad is like the complete opposite and it's like completely like he's not completely anxious but he's very anxious and very existential and very like in his own head about very deep things and it's really funny like seeing it like me and my sister's always joke that it was like you know one of us got my mom's jeans and my other me and my other sister got my dad's jeans
感觉就像，天哪，如果我能换一下，我完全需要。所以这很有趣，我能看到这一点。是的。但话说回来，就像我和我姐姐——不是为了讲她的故事，而是我们在面对神经质以及其他事情（比如宜人性和所有这些）时，采取了非常不同的方法。
and it was like damn like if I could switch like I totally need. So it's funny how I can see that. Yeah. Yeah. But then again, it's like me and my sister like, not to like tell her story, but had that had very different approaches to like how we face neuroticism and like and other things as well and like agreeableness and all those things.
而且在我们的应对方式以及作为人的改变上，确实存在差异。所以我扯远了。我真正想探讨的是你在自己身上发现了什么。但我们要进行一个小小的……
And like there definitely has been a difference in like how we've approached it and how we've changed as people. So I'm ranting. Really what I want to get to is what you found in yourself. But we're going to take a tiny. break and we'll be back in just a second. Stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental
休息，一会儿就回来。请收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及建立适应力的科学。
toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier 的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
收听《2%》。即数字“2”、字母“W”、“O”，以及百分号，可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍了两次小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金姆有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回首当年》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know.
我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。明确一下，84年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，但只是想让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast.
我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客上收听《回首当年》。
or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
或者在任何你获取播客的地方。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学步》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验……
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯蒂芬·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两种不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search Learn the Hard Way and listen now.
我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难学步》中，进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用，搜索《艰难学步》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's,
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父亲身份丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这件事还没完。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud, charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。我们邀请了奥尔加·哈赞回到节目中，讨论我们能否改变性格？这也是整个采访的核心。发生了什么？首先，你做了什么？其次，你发现了什么？是的。这就是整本书的内容。所以让我把它拆解开来，我们先来谈谈外向性，因为我认为这是最容易理解的，而且也得到了最清晰的结果。好的，酷。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We are back with Olga Hazan talking about, can we change our personality? This is kind of the crux of this whole interview. What happened? Firstly, what did you do? And secondly, what did you find? Yeah. So that's like the whole book. So let me just break it down into, let's talk about extraversion first, because I think that is like the easiest to wrap your head around and also has had the clearest results. Okay, cool.
所以外向性，基本上提高外向性的秘诀就是与人社交。其他一些特质则更加存在主义，更偏向思维导向，比如你如何看待事物。外向性非常明确，去和人说话，去参加活动。所以我报名参加了一堆活动。我报名了即兴表演、帆船俱乐部、一堆见面会小组。也就是一群陌生人聚在一起，字面意思上的聚会。我在家里办了一场派对。
So extraversion, basically the secret to increasing extraversion is to socialize with people. Some of the other traits are more existential and more like mindset oriented and kind of like how you think about things. Extroversion is like very clear cut, go talk to people, like go do activities. So I signed up for a bunch of stuff. I signed up for improv, sailing club, a bunch of meetup groups. Which is like groups of strangers meeting up, literally. I like through a party at my house.
我一直在往外跑。我基本上从每周出门一次变成几乎每天晚上都出门，或者——也不是说出去喝酒，虽然有很多酒……我可以想象……就像只是和人在一起……我发现几乎每次出门前我都感到害怕。我不想去。我想，我讨厌即兴表演，我甚至不知道我在做什么，这太蠢了……我不想去。然后几乎每次做完之后我都感觉好多了。我心想，这太有趣了，或者今天帆船课上的那个人真有趣，或者这很酷，或者——嘿，我在回家的路上得买个汉堡。通常总会有一些收获让我觉得，嗯，这是对一天生活的一个美好调剂。
I just went out all the time. I went from basically going out maybe once a week to going out like pretty much every night or like not and not like going out drinking like although there was a lot of drinking um i can imagine like like just being around people um and i found that like almost every time before i went i dreaded it i did not want to go i was like i hate improv i don't even know what I'm doing this stupid like I don't want to go and then almost every time after I would do it I felt better I was like, that was super fun or like that person in the sailing, my sailboat today was really interesting or like, that was cool or like, hey, like I got to get whatever a burger on the way back home. Like there was something that came out of it usually that I was like, huh, that was like a nice break from the day.
我以前总是经常出门。我基本上从可能一周出门一次，变成几乎每天晚上都出门，倒也不是说去喝酒——虽然确实喝了不少，呃，我可以想象——就只是跟别人在一起。我发现几乎每次去之前我都觉得很煎熬，一点也不想去，心想：我讨厌即兴表演，我甚至不知道自己在搞什么鬼，这太蠢了，我才不想去。然后几乎每次演完之后，我都感觉好多了，心想：这太有趣了，或者今天在帆船上那个人真的很有趣，或者这感觉挺酷的，或者，嘿，回家的路上还能顺便买个汉堡什么的。总会有一些收获，让我觉得，嗯，这算是从日常生活中抽离出来的一个不错的放松方式。
That was like a nice way to like liven up the day a little bit. And I think that's kind of like the, when I talk about increasing extroversion or like changing your introversion, you can remain an introvert, but just do like 20% more stuff, like connect with people 20% more. And there's a little bit of a mood boost there. Like researchers who are introverts have studied this concept and have found that like even just connecting with people a little bit. And it doesn't mean that you have to be like the life of the party.
这就像是让生活稍微活跃一点的好方法。而且我觉得这就是，当我谈到增加外向性或者改变内向性时，你依然可以是个内向的人，但只需多做20%的事情，比如多与人建立20%的联系。这样就会带来一点情绪上的提升。比如身为内向者的研究人员研究过这个概念，发现哪怕只是和别人稍微接触一下。这并不意味着你必须成为派对上的灵魂人物。
Like I think people assume extroversion means like you're super talkative and like can't shut up and, you know, or you're always telling jokes. You can like go hang out with two close friends and like, you know, listen more than you talk and like knit the whole time. And that's still extroversion. That's, you know, still being around people. So yeah, for that one, my introversion, my extroversion did go up. And I think what I took away from that is that like I do enjoy having fun. I need to sometimes force myself to have fun.
我觉得人们会认为外向意味着你非常健谈、说个不停，你知道的，或者你总是在讲笑话。你可以和两个亲密的朋友出去玩，你知道的，多听少说，一直在那里织毛衣。这依然是外向。这，你知道的，仍然是在人群中。所以，是的，就这一点而言，我的内向，我的外向确实提升了。我觉得我从中得到的感悟是，我确实很享受乐趣。我有时需要强迫自己去寻找乐趣。
But it's okay to do that. Like it's okay to be like commit, you know, kind of to an exercise class or to something else that doesn't sound super appealing all the time, but ends up being rewarding. This is what I always say. Like people will DM me be like, how do I make new friends or like how do I stop feeling like everything is an effort? And I'm like, pick two things to do a week. and do them in the same place at the same time.
但这样做是可以的。就像你可以去承诺，你知道的，去上健身课或者做一些其他事情，虽然听起来可能并不总是那么吸引人，但最终会得到回报。这就是我常说的。人们会私信我问，如何结交新朋友，或者如何不再觉得每件事都很费劲？我会说，一周挑两件事去做。并且在同一时间、同一地点去做。
And you will meet other people who are doing the same thing as you. Like whether it is it an exercise class or like an improv class or a life during class or like social sport, there are so many people out there who also want to make friends and who also are like seeking connection. And there's like no shame about it either of being like, okay, I'm trying to train my brain to like this more because you do fall into a habit. Like I'm such an extroverted person and last week I spent the entire day at my house and like the entire week, like indoors working and I had such cabin fever. And I was like, I've just, I'm just so depressed. Like, I just don't know who I am anymore. And then I went and did like, barefoot bowls with my friends. And I was like, wow, like, life is so beautiful. Like,
你会遇到其他也在做同样事情的人。无论是健身课、即兴表演课、生活课还是社交运动，外面有很多人也想交朋友，也都在寻找人际连接。而且这也绝对没什么好羞愧的，去想“好吧，我正在训练我的大脑去更喜欢这个”，因为你很容易陷入一种习惯。比如我是一个非常外向的人，上周我在家里呆了一整天，就像整整一周一样，都在室内工作，我得了严重的幽闭恐惧症。当时我就想，我真的是，我太沮丧了。就像，我简直不知道自己是谁了。然后我和朋友们去玩了草地滚球。当时我就觉得，哇，生活太美好了！就像，
look at those flowers. It's like, yeah, giving your brain what it needs. Um, so extraversion was the one that you saw an improvement in. What about neuroticism? Yeah. So neuroticism, I also saw an improvement. So neuroticism, I will cut to the chase. I meditated a whole lot. I, and meditation is also something that I did not enjoy. I didn't even enjoy it while I was doing it. And I did not enjoy it after I was done. I was not like, that was really nice. That sounds painful. Thank God, I don't have to do that for another 24 hours. I signed up for a class where we had to meditate for 45 minutes every day, which is so long. It's literally the longest 45 minutes of your life. However, it's, did work. My neuroticism went down and my anxiety went down a little bit, but my depression
看看那些花。这就好比，顺应大脑的需求。嗯，所以外向性是你看到有改善的一个方面。那神经质呢？是的。所以神经质，我也看到了改善。关于神经质，我直接切入正题。我做了大量的冥想。我，而且冥想也是我原本并不喜欢的一件事。我在做的时候甚至不喜欢它。结束之后我也不喜欢。我不会觉得，这感觉真好。听起来真痛苦。谢天谢地，我接下来24小时不用做了。我报名参加了一个课程，我们必须每天冥想45分钟，这太久了。这绝对是你一生中最漫长的45分钟。然而，它确实起作用了。我的神经质下降了，我的焦虑也稍微减轻了一点，但我的抑郁
went down a ton. It went down a lot like to basically like not being depressed anymore. And why that happened is sort of anyone's guess. If I had to like posit why that occurred, it's that I did a lot of what's called loving kindness meditation, which is where you're just like really nice to yourself for however long. And it's usually, I do it to like a guided, like a tape basically. People don't use tape anymore. Like a recording, like a guided. Yeah, exactly. Like a guided recording. And it's like, you know, like there's like the line that always makes me cry is like there's, you can search the whole universe for someone who is more deserving of love in happiness than you are yourself and not find anyone. And it's like, like, you're like,
大幅下降了。它下降了很多，基本上可以说是“不再抑郁”了。至于为什么会这样，谁也说不准。如果非要让我假设为什么会发生这种情况，那就是我做了很多所谓的“慈心冥想”（loving kindness meditation），也就是不管持续多久，你都真的对你自己非常好。通常情况下，我会跟着一个录音，基本上就像磁带一样来做。现在人们不用磁带了。就像一个录音，一个引导式。对，没错。就像一个引导式录音。然后里面有，你知道的，有一句总是让我哭出来的话，那就是，你可以在整个宇宙中搜寻，也找不到一个比你自己更值得拥有爱与幸福的人。然后你就会觉得，
oh, yeah. And you're just like, oh, my God. You need to know what this tape is. So it's, it's Sharon Salzberg. And I use the 10% happier app for meditation. Oh, I love that app. Yeah, yeah. I have a podcast. It's up from the Yale. Is it from the Yale person? No. I think you I'm thinking of Judd Brewer, the 10% happier is Dan Harris. Oh, yeah, Dan Harris. Yes, yes, yes. Yes. He does Pocas as well, I think.
哦，是的。然后你就会觉得，哦，天哪。你得知道这个磁带是什么。所以，它是，这是莎伦·萨尔茨堡（Sharon Salzberg）的。我用的是“10%更幸福”（10% Happier）冥想应用。哦，我很喜欢那个应用。对，对。我有一个播客。它是从耶鲁大学来的吗？不是的。我觉得，我想的是贾德·布鲁尔（Judd Brewer），“10%更幸福”的主持人是丹·哈里斯（Dan Harris）。哦，对，丹·哈里斯。是的，是的，是的。对。我想他也做播客。
Yes. Yeah. I mean, everyone has a Pocos is so embarrassing. But he, yeah, but it actually like really worked. I think like there's something about like repeating that. I don't know. And my meditation teacher also really tried to like hammer home the self compassion. And I think it worked.
是的。对。我是说，每个人都有个播客，太尴尬了。但是他，是的，但它实际上真的很有效。我觉得，不断重复那个东西。我不知道。我的冥想老师也真的很努力地向我们灌输自我同情。我觉得它起作用了。
Yeah. Wow. See, I get this like meditation. I've never met someone who's been like, I'm really into it all the time. Like, I do feel like you kind of have to drag yourself into it, kicking and screaming. It's like when you have to like get a needle and you're like, I really don't want to do this or like go to the dentist or like go to the doctor and then you feel amazing. Like, oh, wow, that pain's gone. Like that's what meditation sounds like.
是的。哇。你看，对于冥想，我从未遇到过谁会说“我一直都很喜欢它”。我觉得你确实得把自己硬拖进去，又踢又闹的。就像你必须打针，然后你心里想“我真的不想做这个”，或者去看牙医，或者去看医生，然后你就会感觉好极了。就像，噢，哇，那种痛苦消失了。这就是冥想给人的感觉。
And it's just like discipline towards your soul, right? in the same way that you exercise your body, like you're exercising your mind, even if it's like tense and uncomfortable and stressful or whatever in the moment like it feels gives you strength later on. I think what it did is made me less afraid of my negative emotions. So you're sitting there like sometimes for hours and you're just like your mind is like going and going and it's silence, you know? And I think what it does is like for me at least, I don't know if this is like correct, but for me at least, it made me, like, inevitably, like, negative feelings will come up during that, but it was sort of just like, it's okay. Like, nothing bad is really happening right now.
这就像是对你灵魂的纪律，对吧？就像你锻炼身体一样，你在锻炼心灵，即使它在当下是紧绷的、不舒服的、有压力的或者别的什么，它也会在以后赋予你力量。我觉得它所做的是让我不再那么害怕负面情绪。所以你有时会坐在那里几个小时，你的大脑一直在运转，周围却是一片寂静，你知道吗？我觉得它所做的是——至少对我来说，我不知道这是否正确——但至少对我来说，它让我，不可避免地，负面情绪在那个过程中会涌现，但它就像是在说“没关系”。现在其实什么坏事也没发生。
You're literally sitting in a room in your house on a cushion, like, meditating. But you kind of have, you still have your same negative, you know, strong emotions if you're someone who's prone to neuroticism. But it, I don't know, it just lets you like, kind of not be as, thrown off by them or like, because bad things are still, I mean, my meditation teacher would say this all the time, like, things happen that you don't like, which is like very simple, but it's like, oh yeah. And like, you're just, you're going to have to deal with that for the rest of your life. And it's all about, you know, do you, you know, your mom, you mentioned is like, so not neurotic. I'm sure bad things happen to her. But she thinks about them in a, like,
你只是坐在家里的一个房间里，坐在坐垫上冥想。但你其实还是会有那种负面、你知道的、强烈的情绪，如果你是那种容易神经质的人的话。但它，我不知道，它只是让你，某种程度上不再那么容易被它们打乱阵脚，或者因为糟糕的事情仍然会发生——我的意思是我那个冥想老师总是这么说，有些事情发生了，你并不喜欢，这听起来很简单，但确实是“哦，是的”。而且，你知道的，你余生都得去处理这些事。这一切都关乎于，你知道吗，你的妈妈，你提到过她，一点也不神经质。我确信她身上也会发生糟糕的事情。但她对这些事情的看法，会以一种，
somehow more Zen way than the average person. I'd love to know her secret. I would love to as well. It's crazy. And she's had a tough life, like, not to give her story. And I have done an episode with her where she talks about it, but not even the full extent. Like, not an easy life. And sometimes I just look at her and I can see, like, there'll be a time that, like, me or my sister will, like, be panicking about something or being like, don't you just see, like, how terrible this is? And I can literally to see her looking at me being like, no, like trying really hard to have empathy for me and being like, I just can't do it. Like she's incredible and like I, she has obviously like learnt what to say, but she doesn't
某种比一般人更禅定的方式。我很想知道她的秘密。我也很想知道。太疯狂了。她经历过艰难的生活，我不是在泄露她的故事。我做过一期关于她的节目，她在节目里谈到了这一点，但甚至都不是全部。生活绝非易事。有时我看着她，我能看出，有时我和我姐姐会对某事感到恐慌，或者说“难道你没看到这有多糟糕吗？”我能字面意义地看到她看着我，眼神仿佛在说“不”，并且非常努力地对我有同理心，心想“我实在做不到”。她太不可思议了，而且她显然学会了该说什么，但她并没有
like feel it in her bones the way that like my dad would or my sister would. So she honestly needs to do like some kind of life course. Like she's pretty incredible. Okay, I want to ask this question that I think everyone is probably, thinking at this point you did all these amazing exercises how long did this last as well like six months this lasted it a year okay a year and when did that experiment end um i honestly only had a year of book leave so it was just like June of uh 22 to June of 2023 okay cool um so like a year a solid year have you found that you've gone back to your old self
像我爸爸或我姐姐那样，从骨子里去感受它。所以她老人家真的应该去参加某种生活大师班。她相当了不起。好吧，我想问这个问题，我觉得大家在这个时候可能都在想：你做了所有这些惊人的练习，这持续了多久？大概六个月，这持续了一年。好吧，一年。那个实验是什么时候结束的？嗯，我老实说，我只有一年的图书假，所以大概是从22年6月到2023年6月。好的，酷。嗯，差不多一年，扎扎实实的一年。你有没有发现，自从那以后，你又回到了原来的自己？
since so in some ways but not in others. Since I did that, I had a baby. And that necessarily like changes a lot about how you're thinking about things, especially in the beginning. But I would say that there's still a lot of things that I carried through into even my life as a, I guess I'm still a new parent technically. So one example is like just reaching out to other moms. So it's a very, um, stressful time when you first have a baby. Like it's just is there's no getting around it. You don't know what you're doing and they're very tiny and they cannot speak to you. And so you're just like, what do you want? So I kind of made a point of reaching out to other moms and like I'm in
有些方面是，但有些方面不是。自从我做了那件事之后，我生了个孩子。这必然会改变你对很多事情的看法，尤其是在刚开始的时候。但我可以说，仍然有很多东西被我带到了生活中，甚至在我作为一个——我想我技术上仍然是一个新手父母的生活中。所以一个例子就是主动联系其他妈妈。当你刚生完孩子时，这是一个非常、非常压力山大的时期。事实就是如此，无可奈何。你不知道自己在做什么，他们又那么小，而且还不会跟你说话。所以你只会想：你到底想要什么？所以我有点刻意去联系其他妈妈，而且我加入了一个
a mom's group that's been really supportive. I also just like really, really try to even in day-to-day life, if I meet another mom with kids the same age, I really try to like reach out and at least see if she's open to the possibility of friendship. And sometimes that means that I, and this is not something I would have done previously. I actually do a lot of reaching out repeatedly. So like if someone, let's say I reach out to someone and they're like, yeah, let's have coffee and we have coffee and we both have a good time. And then some time elapses and no one follows up.
非常支持人的妈妈群。我也只是非常、非常努力地，甚至在日常生活中，如果我遇到另一个带着同龄孩子的妈妈，我都会真正尝试去联系，至少看看她是否对建立友谊持开放态度。有时这意味着我——这不是我以前会做的事。实际上我做了很多次主动联系。所以比如如果有人，假设我联系了某个人，她们说“好的，我们喝杯咖啡吧”，然后我们喝了咖啡，双方都玩得很开心。接着一段时间过去了，没有人再跟进。
I might reach out again, even though it was me the last time, too. And then I might do that like a third time. Like there are some relationships where I'm just always the person who organizes things. And that used to really bother me. Like I was like, that person doesn't want to be friends. Like, I'm going to move on because they're not putting an equal effort into organizing things. And like, I don't want that.
我可能会再次联系，尽管上一次也是我主动的。然后我可能还会进行第三次。有些关系中，我总是那个组织活动的人。这过去真的很让我困扰。我会想：那个人根本不想跟我做朋友。我要往前走了，因为她们在组织活动上没有付出同等的努力。我才不要那样。
But I kind of just realized through this that like everyone has stuff going on. And like people just don't think about things the same way. They are maybe swamped in other ways. They're maybe like not as comfortable with reaching out. Like I don't know. It just made me like a lot less sensitive, I guess, about these like rules of social interaction that I had previously thought were like iron like laws. So that's been one thing that I've noticed like yesterday we went on a play date to this woman who I like barely knew just because I was like, I'm really bored. and if I have to like sing baby beluga one more time and then I lose my mind.
但我通过这件事突然意识到，每个人都有自己的事情要忙。而且人们只是对事情的看法不同。他们可能在其他方面忙得不可开交。他们可能不那么习惯主动联系。我不知道。这让我对以前认为是铁律的社交互动规则，变得不那么敏感了，我想。所以这是一件我注意到的事情——昨天我们和一位我几乎不认识的女士进行了一场约玩（play date），仅仅是因为当时我想：我真的太无聊了。如果我再唱一遍《小贝鲁加》（Baby Beluga），我就要疯了。
So it's like, let's go over to you chen's house. And yeah, that's what we did. And it was great, you know, so I don't know. I think it's like a really interesting like how you can, it's quite personal, but like whether you would have been a different kind of mother if you hadn't done this experiment, like the year before you had a baby. And like maybe the answer is no, but maybe it's like, wow, like in this weird way, Like maybe you were preparing your personality for like literally the biggest challenge on planet
所以我想，我们去陈（Chen）家吧。是的，我们就这么做了，感觉很棒，你知道的。所以，我不知道。我觉得这真的很有趣，就像你可以——这相当私人，但比如如果你在生孩子前的那一年没有做这个实验，你是否会成为一个不同类型的母亲。也许答案是否定的，但也许就像，哇，以这种奇怪的方式，也许你是在为地球上字面意义上最大的挑战做人格上的准备。
Earth. Like I heard this quotes like when you become a parent, you have to use every single skill that you've ever put on a resume. Like, and the ones that you haven't. So it would be interesting to see that. Not that you wouldn't have been a very competent capable mother if you hadn't have done this. But it's, yeah, it's fascinating. Like I would have loved to see a control group.
就像我听过的一句话：当你成为父母时，你必须动用你在简历上写过的每一项技能。还有那些你没写过的。所以看到这一点会很有趣。并不是说如果你没有做过这些，你就不会成为一个非常称职、有能力的母亲。但，是的，这太迷人了。我真的很想看看对照组的表现。
I know. I'm not very competent or capable as it is. But I will say that I think that doing this experiment helped me decide to have a baby. Oh, okay, cool. Interesting. Like, it helped me get more comfortable with the idea of having a baby. Yeah. Because babies, listen, I don't have one, but they seem like a lot of work.
我知道。我本来也没有那么称职或能干。但我得说，做这个实验确实帮助我下定决心要个孩子。哦，好吧，酷。很有趣。就像，它帮助我更能接受要一个孩子的想法。是的。因为孩子们，听着，我虽然没有孩子，但他们看起来需要付出很多努力。
They are. And they seem like they will put you in like a state. Like, they will bring up all those challenges. So, you know, the other day, this is like so funny, but I didn't realize you can't give babies water. not until six months see guys i don't know if any of you did know that listeners of the podcast but i was like wow if i had a kid right now and and no one had told me that like that would have been a real problem like what are the other things that i don't know about this like grand you end up you end up googling don't worry about that stuff don't don't worry about it right now
确实如此。而且他们似乎会把你带入某种状态。比如，他们会带来所有这些挑战。所以，你知道的，前几天，这太搞笑了，我竟然不知道你不能给婴儿喂水。直到六个月大——听众朋友们，我不知道你们播客的听众里有没有人知道这一点，但当时我想：哇，如果我当时有个孩子，而没有人告诉我这件事，那可真是个大问题了。还有什么是关于这个我不知道的？——最终你会去谷歌搜索的，别担心那些事情，现在先别担心。
it's honestly you will let you'll be googling you will google the internet has answers you google everything no one knows any of those stuff before they start let me go guys and I think it will be a long time. But I've got one final question for you, and I ask every single guest on the podcast, this same question, what advice would you have for listeners in their 20s? What's one thing that you'd wish you'd known earlier?
老实说，你会去谷歌搜索的。你会上网去搜，互联网无所不知，你什么都会去搜。大家在开始之前谁也不知道这些。好了，各位，我觉得时间差不多了。但我有一个最后的问题要问你，这也是我向播客的所有嘉宾都会问的同一个问题：对于二十多岁的听众，你有什么建议？有什么是你希望自己能早点知道的？
And it doesn't have to be about what we talked about today. I would say that my advice for people in their 20s is that it's okay to just pursue what you want. You don't have to do something that seems, practical or like what other people want you to do or just because you've always been doing it. You can, it's a time of life when you can completely pick the thing that is your biggest goal, the thing you most want in the world and just go at it with full force. That's what I would, I would recommend doing.
这不一定非得关于我们今天讨论的话题。我想我对二十多岁的人的建议是，去追求你想要的东西是可以的。你不必去做那些看起来很实用、或者符合别人期望的事情，也不用仅仅因为你一直都在做它。你可以，这是人生的一个阶段，你可以完全挑选那个作为你最大目标、世界上最想要的东西，然后全力以赴地去追求它。这就是我建议去做的。
I also love that. I love that piece of advice. I would give that advice myself. Oh, good. Which is brilliant, which is so brilliant. I want to thank you for coming on the podcast. Where can the listeners find you? Actually, I want to give a shout out to an article that you wrote that I think would be really amazing.
我也很喜欢这个。我很喜欢这个建议。我自己也会给出这个建议。哦，太好了。这太棒了，简直太棒了。我想感谢你来到我们的播客。听众们可以在哪里找到你？其实，我想特别推荐你写的一篇文章，我觉得那篇文章真的很棒。
It's called The Joy of Underperforming. I think you wrote it like a couple of years ago maybe. But if you guys are looking for further listening, for further reading, I'm sorry, old grown and not even let you give your own recommendations. I will in a second. But I remember reading that article that you wrote and being like, wow, this is incredible for people in their 20s. Oh, thanks. It's great.
它叫做《不全力以赴的快乐》（The Joy of Underperforming）。我想可能是你几年前写的吧。但如果你们想寻找更多的聆听内容，寻找更多的阅读内容，抱歉，老气横秋地甚至都没让你自己给出推荐。我一会儿就说。但我记得读过你写的这篇文章，当时觉得：哇，这对于二十多岁的人来说太不可思议了。哦，谢谢。这很棒。
But where else can they find you? Yeah. So our website is TheAtlantic.com. And I'm a writer there. I can find me and all my brilliant colleagues there. And you can find my book, which is called Me But Better, wherever books are sold. I'm very excited for it to come out. It comes out today.
但他们还可以在哪里找到你？嗯，我们的网站是TheAtlantic.com。我是那里的作家。你可以在那里找到我和我所有才华横溢的同事。你可以在任何售书的地方找到我的书，书名叫《更好的我》（Me But Better）。我非常高兴它即将出版。它今天就要上市了。
If you're listening to this, the day that it launched this is released, you can literally go and pre-order a copy. And I know we had quite a few spoilers, but having already read a few chapters slash pages of this book, like there is. much more there and so much more science and research and just like fascinating tidbits. So thank you so much, Olga, for coming on the show. And as always, if there is someone that you know who would like to listen to this episode who you think would be interested in this topic, feel free to send them a link.
如果你在节目发布的当天听到这个，你实际上可以直接去预订一本。我知道我们剧透了不少，但如果你已经读过这本书的几个章节或几页，你会发现里面还有更多内容、更多的科学与研究，以及各种迷人的小花絮。所以非常感谢奥尔加（Olga）来到我们的节目。和往常一样，如果你认识某个人会喜欢听这一期节目，或者你认为他们会对这个话题感兴趣，请随时把链接发给他们。
Make sure that you are following along. If you want to read us five stars, that would be very much appreciated. Until next time, thank you for listening and stay kind. Be safe. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
确保关注我们。如果你想给我们打五星好评，我们将不胜感激。直到下次，感谢收听，保持善良。注意安全。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay.
体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己从另一端走出。收听《2%》。即数字2加百分号。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。1984年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。我是说，那真的是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看》（Look Back at It）。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难的学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不安全，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去这样做。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难的学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，“单身汉”（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你在这个特定的测试上做了两次手脚，对吗？我做了一次手脚。这动用了大批网络侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格（Greg），一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。